>From the logs, we know that we have the right forecast
data and it's in the right format that we want as
an array of strings. So it's finally time to update the
UI. Think back on how AsyncTasks are able to pass data
back onto the main thread. You can hit Ctrl+O to see
the list of available methods we can override in AsyncTask. If
you click on any of them, it will be prepopulated in
the code for you. Then, you can update ArrayAdapter with the new
data that was retrieved by the AsyncTask. As a hint, you
can make the ForecastAdapter be a global variable. That way, you
can access it from within the FetchWeatherTask. Make sure that this
is not a static class, otherwise, you won't be able to
access the member variable from the forecast fragment. Then, go ahead
and compile and build the app. When you run it, and
you hit the refresh button, you should see a week's worth
of weather data for your location. Once it's working, you can
remove the verbose log statements so you don't
clutter the logs. As you're working on this
code, if you see an unsupported operation exception,
make sure that when you're creating the fake
data, that when you initialize ArrayAdapter, you passed
in a list of strings, and not an
array. That way you can call the clear
method or the add method on this list collection.